hello and welcome to the eight PI game
tutorial video with Python 3 where we
left off we generate our blocks we crash
if we run into the blocks or the side of
the screen and now what we want to do is
we want to have some sort of scoring
system and then we can take this scoring
system not only to track our progress
but also measure our progress in the
game and then increase difficulty based
on the progress so with that let's go
ahead and get started so the first thing
we're going to want to do is you want to
have some sort of way of doing a scoring
system ok so probably the best thing to
do is like you just put the score like
the top left or something like that or
the top right so what we're going to go
ahead and do is we're going to go we're
going to put it in the top left for now
and what we're going to need first of
all is some sort of function that's
going to do that for us so I'm going to
call mine define things underscore
dodged and this function is going to
have one parameter and that's going to
be count so like how many things have we
dodged and what we're to do is basically
every time a screen is reset a block is
reset
we're going to say well we dodged it so
we'll add 1 to the count but as far as
displaying this count we just needed to
say font and define font and we're going
to use PI game dot font dot sis font
such as this default system font
basically none and then we'll do 25 and
then we're going to say text equals font
render and we're going to render to
screen dot oops dodged and then colon
and then we'll add a space here plus
string of count so the string version of
you know the count whatever it is and
then we'll use anti-icing and then we're
going to use the color black for things
dodged so that's going to put it on our
screen now we actually have to
you calculate that so before our loop
starts we're going to need to we start
at zero so we'll say we'll just say
dodged equals zero so we have a starting
number here and then every time we reset
so we ask this question like if thing is
greater than to display height so we're
asking there if if that's happened then
we don't run this right the next
question or the next thing what we'll do
here is we'll say dot get dodged plus
equals one and then that's all we really
need to do there and then also before or
I guess I guess right after we draw car
since this is where we're kind of
drawing everything is like right around
here we'll do that as well so we'll say
those things underscore Dodge and then
the count was just this dodged variable
things underscore dodged I believe is
what we used yet okay so that should
display to our screen our score
hopefully and it did not close those PI
games but it D things dodged dodged um
oh well we forgot to do is we didn't
blitt it to the screen so every time
that we want to we can make something
then we kind of put it in this in the
background and then we'll display it so
we have two blitt so do that we're going
to do game display and then we run dot
blitt what do we want to blitt well we
want to blitt text and then where do we
want to blowed it and that's going to be
zero zero so it'll save let's run that
again there we go so now we have dodged
up here and oh watch out okay so now
let's going up every time we actually
dodge one of these things so cool now
close out of this okay
and so now we've got this score that
goes up every time that we dodged
something but the game is still pretty
boring yeah we're tracking progress but
we're not actually doing anything in the
progress so one of the things that we
can do is we can just make this
progressively more and more difficult so
we can come over here and every time we
do dodge plus equals one we also know
that what we've dodged 1 so we don't
have to actually like reference that
variable at all we just know that like
oh it's been reset so the other thing
that we can do is we could say a thing
well first we could do a couple things
one we could speed up the things so our
things are things have a speed of 7
right now let's make it 3 to start um or
4 a thing speed what we can do is we can
say thing underscore speed plus equals 1
so every time we have one to our score
we're also going to do plus 1 to the
speed of the objects so we'll save and
run that so it starts off relatively
slow kind of starts speeding up getting
faster even faster and just each time we
dodge one they get a little quicker on
us pretty soon this is going to be
impossible to dodge if you get one
that's anyway so you can do that and
pretty much make your game nearly
impossible the other thing that we can
do as well is things speed plus equals 1
for now I'm just going to comment this
out um we can we can increase that in a
variety of ways the other thing we can
do is we can change width and height of
the things that we're trying to avoid so
for example we could do thing the
hardest one would be width but if you
change the height it just means that you
have to wait that much longer to get
somewhere generally the safest place to
be would be like right in the middle as
we get things bigger but you'll see what
I mean in a second so we can say thing
width thing underscore whit plus equals
and then we'll grow it compared to our
score or our dodged amount so we can say
plus equals dodged times like 1 point
- or something like that just to slowly
make it a little bigger a little bigger
a little bigger so we'll save it on that
and so you can see the first one
obviously is one hundred hundred pixels
that one got a little bit wider or at
least it should have I can't tell
visually if they're getting wider or not
we did do plus II was all this green man
I want to see one on the screen yeah it
looks like they're definitely getting
slightly wider that was no longer a box
this would go a lot faster if we sped up
the pace as well but yeah you can see
they're getting definitely wider and
wider and wider still easy to avoid for
the most part and that's why I kind of
like to pick up the pace a little bit
just to add slightly more challenge to
it so for example we'll just exit out
okay and we'll also do things speed plus
equals one and get started here so nice
slow pace to begin and then things start
going getting out of hand here pretty
soon probably that's your bad at start
huh it's pretty easy
no problem Oh perfect goodness
Oh a little harder harder still maintain
in my middle position oh my god they're
moving too fast
oh good is challenge anybody to beat my
score oh man that was impossible so
eventually the game gets pretty much
impossible but just want to give you
guys a couple ideas about how you can
kind of increase the difficulty you
don't have to increase it even this fast
you could you can change things speed
doesn't have to go up by one either you
could go slower than that so the next
thing I want to do is just cover a
couple look for example as you saw if
the blocks get big enough for you
crashing to the side our text isn't
really the best color for text or maybe
it's our blocks that aren't the best
color for our blocks so now I just want
to cover really quickly um we can change
a few things first of all you always
want to make sure for example your score
is drawn last
that way nothing overlaps the score so
you always want to make the score
drawing lines because when someone
crashes or something if something is
overlapping their score they're going to
be relatively angry because they can't
see their score so you want to do that
and luckily we're already doing that but
then you could change the color of the
score - so our score is black so
something that's black covers the score
we're not going to we're not going to
see it anyways like they're going to
mesh so we want to change the color now
at least for me you can go on to like
various websites and you can find like
you can look up RGB color codes you can
get like a color wheel and select a
specific color for now I'm just going to
give you guys some but yeah you can look
them up or you can even go to like paint
and usually you can like pick a color
and paint like this and then you can
just take the red green and blue values
of that as well so you can do that um so
I'm going to say a block underscore
color equals and the color I was going
to use was 53 115 255 and then block
color will copy that and then we're
going to come down to where we draw our
things and color will just be this right
here so we'll say block color or
actually well we're passing through
colors so actually we need to do that
when we call things here so we call it
black will say block color so we can
save and run that
and now we have like this blue okay and
now you crashed it could overlap the
blue wouldn't be a big deal
our score is drawing last will always
see score and all that so you can
obviously change the colors and do that
kind of stuff so that's really the
basics that I wanted to cover with
pygame obviously there's a whole lot of
stuff that you can do with pygame you
can make all kinds of games you can
check out PI game dot org and just look
at all of the games people make
hopefully now that you have a lot of the
basics of Pi game down you could look at
various games and kind of see how they
do it
someone did ask me to give a slight
challenge at the end of some of my
series here and so I think the challenge
I'm going to give you guys is adding
multiple blocks without hard coding it
so what I mean by that is you have maybe
a counter here that says a thin count
and you obviously start at one but one
of the other ways that we could increase
difficulty is by increasing the number
of blocks not increasing their size
necessarily but just adding more tat to
have to dodge and so and so you could do
that instead of an increase size and
speed or do some sort of combination of
those things so my challenge would be
adding more more things to avoid without
hard-coding them in as in not doing
something like things and then making a
function for like like this like things
too and things three like not building a
function for that but just adding them
in like a for loop or something like for
fourth thing and range of thing count
and then creating on that way so good
look anyway I might add on to this
probably not I just wanted to get one
out there for Python 3 so anyway if you
guys have any questions or comments or
have ideas on how to improve this game
pretty sure we can also improve this
function here
I believe this statement here there is
probably I think there's a flaw on this
statement as well I'll let someone it's
just a redundancy real
in this statement that we don't really
need to ask but anyway I'll leave that
to homework as well if you guys want but
anyways if you guys have any questions
or comments or improvements feel free to
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time